welcome to this video playing Fur dr
fudia let's see an English Defence yeah
on it's New Years Eve I mean not at the
moment when i'm recording but at the
moment of release and I'm on a winning
Street of 13 out of 13 so trying run
form this big 2500 rating yeah he's
playing a really good line yeah hmm how
do you did essentially this island of
course that essentially oh let's see 94
the English Defence it is a slightly
shaky opening but interesting to play
let's see how can I get some tech going
against his center what is not exactly
perfectly coordinated I'm looking at the
g2 porn which is important you cannot so
easily develop deform Queen h4 is an
interesting move trying to threaten
Bishop Queen edge for you it's quite
interesting if he moves his bishop on f1
I take g2 and I'm threatening our Bishop
before threatening yeah intending he
let's say and also knight c6 may putting
putting pressure on the d4 pawn it's not
easy to play this kind of position the
white center is somewhat exposed ok I
figure if I Oh knight c6 Bishop to e3 em
maybe we should be 3d6 trying to try to
be really quickly ever like if he takes
I mean II five hangs so he has to take
care about it somehow I think and I
after taking Bishop takes I am ready for
long castles which really looks quite
nice putting pressure on the pawn on d4
yeah that's not easy to play for wine at
all very often white players who play 1c
for their struggle with the English
Defence II would be six because it's
sometimes really a little bit irrational
and and difficult to assess and they
don't get this so often and in the
English you're very often the English
opening 1 C for your very often used to
playing a bit like pattern pattern chess
yeah which is not a bad thing I mean
thinking in general concept and so on
but in the English Defence you sort of
force to would be six you're sort of
forced to play very concrete stuff
that's interesting actually at first I
thought that Bishop g3 is just winning a
piece but he has aged takes of course um
I can take which is not bad how to keep
the Queen's on really am queen f6 looks
kind of weird let's take it I didn't
want to trade queens but okay I still
have the deep aunt to to play against
rookie eight
and possibly Bishop e7 g6 Bishop f6 okay
hmm interesting Bishop f3s may be coming
but let's start with this move first it
would want the night you come to have
six or something and I can at least them
I have a nice time advantage okay let's
let's trade this thing I also can play
96 checking his c4 pond
I'm actually fire head on the clock it's
nice right a5 is also also a threat this
is a real threat he cannot protect the
point isn't it and c5 you really don't
want to play giving me the d5 square oh
[Music]
well isn't a five good now a five by
then c5 okay okay let's just do that
checking the a pawneean it should be
quite nice
a three is hard to protect you can play
forward then 85 that's just good okay
take a chance that's a good square
[Music]
protecting a seven but keeping an eye on
D on d4 and d5 is nicely security anyway
now so look look t7 I guess property
7028
[Music]
yeah maybe just to get the night over to
d5
[Music]
not totally sure about it but he didn't
even play neither foursome and I can't
he can't play night afore now I have aya
survive whoops oops what is this okay
this I didn't really think about it all
now I can really just take it Bishop g5
king of eight just take every porn
that's available um ano g6 gifts gets me
into an awkward pin so I better do this
age I rh5 maybe look G seven or
something trying to try to be be a
nuisance f6d I have six I really some
nine seconds so I kind of I will win
this on time but I really am just a
couple of pounds up he has no no real
counterplay white foreheads on time yeah
this was was quite quite ok I think this
was an interesting position out of the
opening here white is suffering a little
bit with this exposed porn and queen age
for was strong with g6 coming 96 maybe
g6 first year but this green age 5 but i
think really yeah I'm okay the computer
actually prefers to Castle long yeah I
didn't want to think about the Jews
having porn going away this is this is
definitely an ok position for for black
here he has to improve you can do
something like this intending b3 and he
shouldn't be in bad shape I'm I like to
be black he is simply because I have an
idea what to do a teching d4 somehow but
white is of course totally solid but
with this he invited me chahta i took
this invitation picking up pawns in the
process and here it was really quite
quite easily winning yeah I hope you
enjoyed it and well have a good New
Year's Eve thanks for watching